maryse doit vendre sa voiture elle
installe donc une affiche
auto à vendre sur la lunette arrière de
sa voiture le matin sur pire elle
découvre une contravention de 52 dollars
sur le pare brise de sa voiture
stationnée devant chez eux
que lui reproche-t-on d'avoir stationné
sur un chemin public son véhicule sur
lequel il affiche à vendre est apposée
naïve n'en revient pas c'est pourtant
vers plusieurs villes du québec
interdise de stationner un véhicule dans
la rue dans le but de lever entre autres
québec gatineau longueuil saguenay et
certains arrondissements de ville de
montréal comme anjou et sachez que le
code de sécurité routière interdit de
conduire un véhicule avec un objet placé
de manière à obstruer la vue du
conducteur selon la taille et
l'emplacement des fiches un policier
pourrait donc et net la contravention
le fin mot de l'histoire pour vendre
votre voiture
affichez vous donc dans le journal ou
sur le web